Joy Behar and the cackling hands at the
view are somewhat impressed by one of
the latest nominees for the presidency
that would be Nikki Haley there were
these politicians on the right who now
have become like mentally crazy you know
but our problem is that you know Not
only was she a big Trump supporter and
I'd like she's an election denial too
isn't she at one point at one point but
she changed she flip-flopped on that but
she also backed Herschel Walker one of
the worst candidates we've ever had I
mean second only May or second only to
George Santos maybe yeah you know that
was terrifying actually that you did
that so I mean she's going an election
I'm not sure she's an election denier I
would check on that okay there you go
this is a warning to all the other GOP
candidates it doesn't matter how much
they like you it doesn't matter how much
you do to try to earn some favor with
the liberal press they will always turn
on you